hot breath well you know we're all
we're we're all unique um
i i'm such a visual guy but i always
used to say
it's like when you used to go to the
mall at christmas time and you just
drive up and down the aisles i said
you're looking for the empty parking
place that's always been my business
approach
i'm looking for the space that nobody's
in
um and so you know it's like a couple of
years ago i'll give you a great example
so
uh a couple years ago thanksgiving
every year at thanksgiving we have like
30 relatives at my farm
we've been doing it forever all the
cousins grandmothers
mom's dads and so the kids and i say
kids they're in their 20s now
but so thanksgiving night they're
sitting around the big table
and one of them pulls out cards against
humanity and they start playing cards
against humanity
which is hilarious but it's
also filthy you know it's just dirty as
it can be
and i went over to him and i said you
your grandmother's here your aunts and
uncles are here you can't play this at
this table
you can play it but you know go
somewhere else because
and and i sat back down and i thought
well crap
and what makes cards against humanity is
there's no strategy you're just doing it
it's funny
and so i thought well there's got to be
a way to do this funny that that grandma
doesn't have to leave the room and aunts
and uncles doesn't have to leave the
room
and so i go in my office and i pull out
a stack of note cards
and i start thinking all right so what
what's a game you could play that would
be funny
and i everybody's got a family that's
why we're here at thanksgiving as a
family everybody's family's crazy
so what if all i my skill set is punch
lines and setups so i wrote
a hundred setups involving relatives
and it was like you know right before we
walked down the aisle daddy leaned over
to me and whispered
blank so that would be a setup and then
i wrote
500 punch lines took me like the next
two days
and then i had them all all the aunts
and uncles and cousins sit down at the
table
and play the game on stupid note cards
and they were and i'm filming it and
they're laughing and i'm like crap
there's something here
because there's there's games of
strategy or whatever but to me if you
play a game and it makes you laugh
you'll play it again
then relative insanity ended up being
like the number one game on amazon
because it was just so that was a that
was a
looking for that empty looking for that
empty parking space
is there had to be a fun again there was
a funny game cards against humanity is
really funny
but the empty space was
your grandma and your aunts and uncles
couldn't play it because it was too
dirty and so it's
looking to go where's the where's a
niche that nobody is in and it can be in
a podcast
it can be in a game it can be in a book
you know it can be in a tv show there's
all kinds of empty spaces
but you know don't try to do what
somebody else
is doing make it
yours you're unique you know find
be be truly i know tell comics that
don't try to
you be true to your voice you be true to
your sensibilities
but look for those open spaces what's
somebody else not doing that
you can pull in there and do
and would it also be kind of like um
thinking of
like the the kings of comedy are working
but there's not that for this
demographic so is it also kind of like
cards against humanity has this audience
but not this audience were you thinking
the same thing with like blue collar
oh yeah the one of the first stops of
the kings of comedy
which was a tremendous comedy tour but
it was atlanta
and i'm reading an article about it in
the paper and it said this is a show
for the urban hip audience
and i called bill involved and i said
look these guys are killing it
for the urban hip audience but that's
leaving a lot of people out because
there's a
i've been all over i've been every state
there's a lot of people that aren't
urban
and they're not helped and i said we
need to do a show for them
and he laughed he said what would you
call it i'm like hell i don't know call
it the blue collar
comedy tour and um
and so again it's like you said i mean
there was an
open space there was nobody had done a
group of four
people going after you know middle class
america
and we were going to do it for three
months and i think we did the first tour
for three years we had no idea it was
going to work
gosh high breath
you